welcome back a bizarre lockdown at a
wyoming high school with a 16 year old
getting arrested and removed from campus
in handcuffs for refusing to wear a mask
that student grace smith and her father
andrew smith are with us now thanks to
the both of you for being here grace
first question to you describe what
happened
um i have been protesting the mask
things with
fellow students for
over the entire school year and i went
to school like normal and i left first
hour
um after coming back for my second
suspension for
my
for them calling it a continued willful
disobedience for not complying to the
mask mandate um i had previously had one
500 citation and during first hour i
went down to the front office and
they
locked me in the lunchroom before i was
even suspended and then gave me a second
500 citation for trespassing after my
suspension and then proceeded to arrest
me after putting the school on lockdown
for an hour and a half even though i was
not a disturbance i just sat in the
lunch room asking to go back to class
locks you away for all intents and
purposes because you weren't wearing a
mask what's going through your head
as this is happening
i thought it was absolutely ridiculous i
wanted to go back to class just so i
could learn and
i never thought that they would actually
arrest me it honestly really surprised
me to see them put me in cuffs and take
me to jail wow andrew as a father how
tough is it to see your daughter being
treated worse than actual criminals in
our country are currently being treated
right now
well it's appalling and uh frankly we
we approach this from a perspective of
constitutional law and in the state of
wyoming the constitutional law
is not only designed to protect us as
individual citizens of this state
but is also um written that the state of
wyoming will step in and act on our
behalf
and we
were just appalled that through this
whole process that nobody
would step in and
act on grace's behalf
and support her her civil liberties um
that were guaranteed to her by the
constitution of wyoming and so it's been
just amazing
to witness
from an outsider's perspective
and appalling frankly that they would
take it this far
and uh
and that nobody through the entire
administration whether it be law
enforcement officers uh city police
chief
county sheriff
governor's office it didn't matter
nobody was
going to
step in and help on her behalf
let's continue to view this through the
prism of being a dad obviously i've got
a very very young daughter but i want to
keep on this dad theme what is your
reaction to your daughter taking a stand
like this
she is a strong
willed child she is brilliant
and amazing
so my reaction through this whole
process has been
that
of support
especially once we figured out that the
mask
policy was unlawful
then
then we were all in and we were gonna do
whatever it took um
so boasting with pride but uh we never
thought that it would go this far
and i'm just uh yeah just so stinking
proud of this girl for standing up for
herself and it's not just her she's
she's doing it for the civil liberties
of every individual so
let's quickly get in the albany kennedy
school district statement i'm going to
paraphrase part of this this morning at
laramie high school there was a brief
lockdown related to a student
disciplinary disturbance in the main
office goes on to have a few more
details all students are safe the
lockdown was issued in order to prevent
further interruptions to academic
learning so there you have it there
grace would you do it again
uh if i had to yes but
at this point it's not safe for me to be
at school because there have been
threats to my family and there was a
threat of a school shooting last friday
so i won't be returning anytime super
soon
all over a mask final question to you
grace what's your message to those who
feel that their rights are being
trampled on whether in this kind of a
context or just in general
um i believe that every right that you
feel is being infringed upon is worth
fighting for and my dad and i have
closed off every meeting with a quote of
benjamin franklin by saying
those who sacrifice a little bit of
liberty for a little bit of safety
deserve neither liberty nor safety what
the heck are we doing that
nice young ladies like yourself are
being threatened you have a gun threat
all because you won't wear a mask you're
being locked away it's a sad state of
affairs but andrew and grace we
appreciate you coming on this morning
and sharing your story with us please
come back keep us posted we're curious
as to how it's all good thanks for
having us thank you